Argentina es famosa por ser el líder mundial en exportación de psicoanalistas. En este
país, el fútbol, el tango y las crisis
económicas son, prácticamente, una tradición
nacional. Pero esto podría cambiar radicalmente
mucho antes de lo que nos imaginamos.
Sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
otra vez más os estoy hablando del LITIO,
el material del que se fabrican las baterías
de los móviles, los ordenadores portátiles
o los coches eléctricos.
Como os decía en este otro vídeo, Argentina
es, junto con Chile y Bolivia, uno de los
tres países que forman el llamado triángulo
del litio. La zona del mundo donde se concentra
entre el 60 y el 80% de este mineral.
Sin embargo, de estos tres países, Argentina
es el país que más atención internacional
ha logrado. Todos los grandes fondos de inversión
tienen sus ojos puestos en este país. Habéis
oído bien. Argentina, el país que hace
unos pocos años tenía las peores calificaciones
crediticias es ahora la niña bonita de las
principales empresas mineras de todo el planeta.
Así que la pregunta es... De verdad puede
liderar Argentina la carrera del litio? ¿Qué
han hecho en este país para mejorar su imagen
exterior? Y lo que es más importante ¿En
qué medida el litio puede convertir a Argentina
en un nuevo Abu Dhabi? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
LOS ARGENTINOS PRIMERO
Durante los últimos años, Argentina se
ha convertido en el hombre saco para los inversores
internacionales. Los que lleváis más tiempo
suscritos a VisualPolitik ya sabéis por
qué.... Bajo la presidencia de CRISTINA FERNANDEZ
DE KIRCHNER, el Gobierno Argentino hizo todo
lo posible para ahuyentar a cualquier empresa
que quisiera invertir en el país.
En el sector minero y petrolero, Kirchner
tampoco se quedó atrás. En 2008 sacó
una ley contra la repatriación de capitales.
Es decir, que si una empresa minera australiana,
por ejemplo, hacía beneficios explotando
petróleo o minerales en suelo argentino,
el Gobierno la prohibía que enviara ese
dinero de vuelta a Australia. El objetivo
de Kirchner era obligar a esos inversores
extranjeros a gastar el máximo dinero posible
dentro del país.
Pero las consecuencias fueron que la mayor
parte de las empresas dejaran de pensar en
Argentina como un país donde invertir. A
fin de cuentas ¿Para qué, si no iban a
poder quedarse con los beneficios?
Sin embargo, el auténtico punto de inflexión
vino en el año 2012.
"Argentina expropia a Repsol su filial YPF"
Para los que no conozcáis la historia, Repsol
es una petrolera española que se fusionó
en 1998 con otra empresa argentina que se llama YPF. Durante muchos años, esta nueva
compañía se llamó Repsol-YPF. Pero un
buen día, Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner,
al más puro estilo Donald Trump, dijo eso
de que "los argentinos primero" hashtag,
MAKE ARGENTINA GREAT AGAIN.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasó después?
Por supuesto, se sucedieron montones de peleas
legales entre Repsol y el Gobierno de Argentina.
Pero eso no es lo peor de todo. El mayor problema
es que esta YPF que ahora estaba nacionalizada,
bajó su producción de petróleo a la
mitad.
"La producción de petróleo argentina
continúa en declive por la ralentización
de la actividad de las plataformas de perforación"
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué tiene que ver
el hecho de que una empresa sea pública
o privada para que produzca más o menos
petróleo? Por supuesto que hay muchas petroleras
públicas que funcionan muy bien. El ejemplo
más claro sería ARAMCO, que pertenece
al gobierno saudí y produce más barriles
de zumo de dinosaurio que ninguna otra compañía.
El problema es que tanto el mundo del petróleo
como el de la minería, en general, requiere
de altísima tecnología. Y, normalmente,
cada empresa tiene sus propias patentes. Dicho
de otra forma, cuando YPF quiere explotar
los yacimientos de Vaca Muerta, necesita utilizar
una técnica muy novedosa que se llama FRACKING,
de la que ya os hemos hablado en otros vídeos.
Y sólo unas pocas empresas tienen las máquinas
necesarias para realizar estos procesos. Por
eso es tan común que, en el mismo sitio,
estan varias compañías distintas cooperando.
Cuando se fue Repsol, la petrolera argentina
perdií a un socio tecnológico. Así que,
Kirchner se enfrentó a esos malvados neoliberales
españoles... para terminar asociándose
con los estadounidenses.
Chevron firma un acuerdo de 1500 millones
de dólares con YPF
Pero esto no es lo peor de todo. El problema
es que cuando expropias una empresa de la
noche a la mañana, al resto de empresarios
se les quitan las ganas de seguir en tu país.
Pensadlo bien. Imaginad que tenéis una empresa
minera ¿Realmente os atreveríais a construir
fábricas y plantas en un país cuyo gobierno
os puede expropiar sin previo aviso? Probablemente
no. Esto, junto a otros factores que explicamos
en este vídeo, explica por qué Argentina
pasa por una de las crisis més duras de
su historia.
Sin embargo, con la llegada al poder de Mauricio
Macri, las cosas han cambiado.
FIEBRE DEL ORO BLANCO EN ARGENTINA
En diciembre de 2015, Mauricio Macri llegó
a la Casa Rosada, que es como la Casa Blanca
pero versión argentina. Se encontró un
país en bancarrota, con una inflación
no oficial que superaba el 40% y donde ninguna
empresa estaba dispuesta a invertir. Y todo
esto, a pesar de ser uno de los países más
ricos en recursos naturales del mundo. Por
eso, desde el minuto 0 de su presidencia,
Macri se ha dedicado a dar un giro de 180 grados
a todo lo que había hecho su predecesora.
"El nuevo gobierno de Argentina elimina
los impuestos especiales a la minería"
En otras palabras, Macri sabe que el litio
podría ser una oportunidad única para
cuadrar las cuentas públicas. Por supuesto
que nadie espera que, de la noche a la mañana,
Argentina se convierta en la nueva Dubai.
Pero este oro blanco es un dinero que llega
caído del cielo con el que el país puede
tapar sus agujeros sin tener que subir impuestos
ni hacer recortes de gasto.
Y eso explica leyes como esta.
"Argentina cierra un acuerdo sobre minería
para unificar todas las legislaciones y atraer
a los inversores"
En otras palabras, a partir de ahora, las
multinacionales mineras tienen las puertas
abiertas para entrar en Argentina sin tener
que asociarse con el gobierno. Además, a
diferencia de lo que ocurría durante la
época de Kirchner, las empresas extranjeras
pueden hacer lo que quieran con el dinero
que obtengan. Y esto ocurre porque el gobierno
de Macri ha anulado la ley que prohibía
la repatriación de los beneficios.
Por si esto fuera poco, la legislación es
uniforme en todo el país. Es decir, que
ya no hay distintas regulaciones dependiendo
de la región en la que se encuentre el yacimiento.
Y estas empresas mineras que inviertan en
Argentina sólo pagarán los impuestos que
pagan las demás empresas.
Pesos pesados de la industria como ALBEMARLE
CORP, SOCIEDAD QUÍMICA Y MINERA DE CHILE,
ERAMET y JIANXI GANGFENG LITHIUM están entre
los grupos que quieren expandir o construir
nuevas explotaciones de litio en Argentina.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo
es tan bonito! Por supuesto que el litio es
una gran oportunidad para Argentina. Pero
ya sabéis que tener muchos recursos naturales
no equivale a ser rico. Y muchos argentinos
tienen miedo de convertirse en un nuevo Potosí.
Durante unos años, el país se llene de
empresas extranjeras que tomen los recursos
y se marchen sin apenas dejar dinero. Así
que la pregunta es ¿Qué puede hacer Argentina
para evitar este desastre?
LA VERDADERA OPORTUNIDAD DE ARGENTINA
Como decíamos en un anterior vídeo dedicado
al litio, el verdadero negocio no es vender
el mineral en bruto sino exportar productos
de valor añadido como las baterías. Para
que os hagáis una idea, en el momento el
que hacemos este vídeo, la tonelada de litio
cotiza por, alrededor de los 9000 USD. Sin
embargo, si tomamos ese litio en bruto y lo
convertimos en baterías para teléfonos
móviles, podemos conseguir unos ingresos
de entre 1.5 y 5 millones de dólares. Por
supuesto que es un cálculo muy aproximado
pero nos permite entender la diferencia entre
vender materias primas o bienes industriales.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo
es tan sencillo!
Casi todas las fábricas de baterías de
litio están en lugares como Estados Unidos,
Alemania o, por supuesto, China. En estos
tres países existe un enorme tejido industrial,
con toda una red de empresas pequeñitas
que proveen de materiales y servicios a las
grandes.
Hablamos de logística, semiconductores,
etc... esto hace que la producción sea más
rápida y barata ... Pero no sólo eso! Este
efecto red también sirve para atraer a los
mejores ingenieros y profesionales especializados,
que son imprescindibles para poder montar
una fábrica de alta tecnología.
¿Y cómo consigues convencer a una chica
que, a lo mejor está en San Francisco cobrando
100.000 dólares al año para que se mude
a Rosario a trabajar en una fábrica? Como
os podíis imaginar, es bastante complicado.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué puede hacer Macri
entonces para industrializar su país?
Lo primero que tenemos que tener claro es
que las fórmulas mágicas no existen y
Silicon Valley no se creó en 2 tardes. Sin
embargo, Argentina tiene una ventaja que no
tenían en California: y esa ventaja es que
ahora pueden hacer dinero rápido con la
venta del litio.
Ese dinero no sólo sirve para que el gobierno
cuadre sus cuentas. También es un colchón
para que el gobierno pueda invertir en universidades
que formen a esos profesionales tan necesarios
para crear las empresas pequeñitas tan necesarias
para que puedan surgir los grandes fabricantes.
Incluso, el Gobierno podría cofinanciar
proyectos empresariales. En otros vídeos
hemos explicado como Israel, por ejemplo,
se ha convertido en otra meca tecnológica
gracias, en parte, a proyectos de cooperación
con el propio estado. En principio, parece
que Macri está decidido a ir en esta dirección.
"Hemos aprendido que, además de nuestro
talento y nuestros enormes recursos naturales
tenemos que añadir constancia, estado de
derecho y predictabilidad"
¡Pero esperad un momento porque también
hay muchos nubarrones! Todas estas oportunidades
que tiene Argentina se irían a pique si
Macri o quien le suceda intenta volver al
ultranacionalismo y espantar a los extranjeros.
Y... por lo que parece Cristina Fernández
de Kirchner quiere volver a presentarse a
las elecciones.
Así que
la pregunta es ¿Puede Argentina restaurar
la seguridad jurídica y convertirse en un
país rico gracias al litio? ¿O volveremos
a ver una nueva crisis en este país? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas. Así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!